ah we back de volu here and you filthy
anime only better click off this video
if you don't want to get spoiled on the
Pinnacle of the battles that happened
inside of the shabuya incident Arc this
fight STS three of the series most
beloved characters who over the space of
six grueling chapters lay their body
soul and future all on their line for
the sake of their own personal game
apart from Toto you know mans here to
back his brother up and double team this
patchy ass creep so anyway sit back
subscribe if you are new around here and
interested in any mult itude of similar
styled anime and Marga content but now
get ready for 120% the greatest portion
of the shabuya incident Arc so kicking
things off and following probably one of
the saddest moments in the series so far
and as noara seemingly lay there still
right in front of his eyes yuji's
resolve shatters taking the opportunity
to possibly take out another stupid
student mahito follows up breaking
yuji's Spirit by battering the
sorcerer's body into the ground and
sealing with his own application of
black flash he kicks him in the head and
proclaims that Yuji came to shabuya with
sympathetic half ass determination that
naivity now is what left him open This
Is War not some Battle of emotions to
fix Sublime issues but a clash of truths
against his fragile Justice he's figured
it out now Yuji and him are one and the
same but he will kill Yuji without a
second thought just like how Yuji saves
people without any hesitation this is
now the instincts of a curse against the
so-called Pride obtained by a b line
human it's a battle to determine who
will be the one standing in 100 years
from now asking the sorcerer how the
hell even thought he'd be able to beat
him or if he has any idea about the
amount of curses he stepped on and
killed mjo he has no response making him
confident that yuji's done for he
jokingly states that he actually cares
about how many people he's taken out
however as he morphs his hand into a
pray mantis appendage screams that he'll
surely forget about Yuji too before
going to slash down on the knockdown out
sorcerer taking him by surprise and just
before the curs spirit lands the killing
blow the sound of a single clap Echoes
through the subway Corridor suddenly mjo
is left discombobulated and Confused
standing in an entirely different spot
in the hallway wondering who the hell
this guy with a scar on his face is
having taken the cursed spirit's Place
one of Kyoto's most handsome men stands
over Yuji peacefully he recites a poem
that conveys the idea that those who
Prosper are also destined to decline in
this world of jiujitsu though there are
some who are considered the exception
and were taking off his jacket and
saying hello to his best friendo Toto
proudly reiterates that they they are
the exception entering the platform
Kyoto's first here Arata rushes up to
Toto's side and informs him that he's
finished trading noara with his curse
technique Arata who takes like a bit
more of a manager role has the ability
painkiller this technique allows Arata
to stop existing injuries from getting
anywhere worse more on their ability in
a second arada sadly doesn't think that
nobra will survive though and asks his
Senpai to not place any blame on him if
she doesn't make it through uninterested
in an idol chatter Toto simply asks
serata to treat his brother as well
snapping his head and yuji's Direction
Toto yells at his broken partner that
it's time to wake up as this fight has
only just begun cooled up and in the
Fatal position Yuji can't bring himself
to get up and fight any longer he
reveals that namami died as well as no
Barra coupled with his guilt over
allowing sakuna to Rampage through the
city the young man is physically unable
to forgive himself screaming out that he
couldn't do anything and that he's
nothing more than a murderer the student
falters and begins to believe that
people would die simply because he lives
Love Struck by yuji's beaten demeanor
mahito leaps at the trio of sorcerers
and attempts to slash at them with his
rated arm blade Toto activates Boogie
wogie to switch a Rider's position on
the ground behind him with mjo's
position in the air he then without
hesitation claps again to swap mahito
with Yuji positioning the cursed Spirit
right back in front of him unable to
block Toto delivers a powerful snap kick
that sends his adversary crashing into
the ground the impact Ricochet mjo
towards Arata but Toto slaps his big
hands together And Trades places so his
Pier doesn't suffer any damage across
the other side of the room mahito
quickly recovers and laughs from the
thrill of grappling with his new
opponent's ability stoically Toto
reiterates to his brother that now he is
amongst men he needed himself with such
narrow mindness they they are jutes who
Sorcerers him Toto nobara and naami they
together are jut who Sorcerers so even
if one is defeated as long as the others
continue to live no one will have ever
truly passed there are no sins or
punishments instead the moment they
choose the life of a sorcerer they
cannot be limited by the death of a
friend one cannot look for meaning or
logic and death and those who do can at
times defile the memories of those who
have passed
throwing his jacket to the ground and
ready to place his life on the line he
asks Yuji what he's been entrusted with
he doesn't need to answer now however
until he finds that answer Toto pleads
with him to never stop moving for those
who live the life of a jutu sorcerer
this is the punishment that they that
they must endure done with getting Yuji
back on track total charges ahead to
face a special great curse Spirit while
a writer applies his technique to yuji's
wounds a writer explains his technique
painkiller as I said Arata can like
pretty much sustain the damage already
occurred so it won't get any worse he
also reveals that he's done the same for
nobara and reassures Yuji that there is
a very small possibility she could
survive it's not a 0% chance of survival
but as he goes to leave with the broken
girl exclaims that he mustn't get his
hopes up of her living but you know what
does the entire freaking Community
decide to go and do for years at this
point now go get their damn hopes up
like oh my Lord at this point can't we
just confirm that most most likely the
girls not around anymore I either way
small tangent over like all of us
Muppets as well reading the series Yuji
also has a spirit slightly reignited
thanks to A's kindness in front of Toto
mahito transforms his torso into a
spiked net and lunges his top half at
the sorcerer with the intention of ens
snaring him Toto claps to change their
positions and reinforces his hand with
cursed energy to grab the knitted part
of mjo's body from behind annoyingly
Toto is just too damn strong and he
straight up tore the knitting apart
allowing the slly dog mjo to transfigure
the back of his body to meridi FRS above
the hulked up beauty that is Toto now
meito nearly grabs down on him but the
sorcerer claps again to get right back
behind his adversary making mjo stumble
forth looking down on him now Toto
taunts mahito asking if the curse even
wants to touch him thinking to himself
meito was impressed with the sorcerer's
ability to dodge while keeping his
distance from Yuji but he still has a
few tricks in store himself randomly and
from behind a small transfer good human
human that mjo like must have dropped
earlier activates and transforms into a
large Spike almost skewering the
sorcerer although his shirt is slightly
cut Toto avoids the spike by simply
adjusting his posture preparing his next
strike mjo hopes that Toto will switch
as right now he sure that he'll
eventually figure it out he can feel it
swelling up inside of him and as time
slows thinks that he wants it again he's
so close he can almost feel the taste
the true essence of his soul ready to
bust forth with another black flash
suddenly a single clap rings out gifting
mjo the moment he wanted yet to his left
now stands our boy having taken the
place of his brother and with his fist
fully imbued in cursed energy
remembering the final words T Nami said
Yuji apologizes for almost taking the
easy Road out and using his sins as an
excuse to run away from everything with
his fist throbbing with cursed energy
Yuji unleashes his point blank black
flash connecting with mjo and shattering
the cursed Spirit guard seing him
rocketing back across the platform
inside of the shabuya station with his
resolve returned yuju remembers his
teacher and tells him that he'll be sure
to take on his share of suffering as
well amused Mito smiles and regenerates
his arm commenting that Yuji that little
rascal is back from the dead finally if
you ask me shes Toto you know he tears
that shirt off ever continuing to
undress himself and welcomes Yuji back
into The Fray of the battle I I don't
even know why I had to do it like that
but I I just had to man I I love this
battle so much just as soon as Yuji is
down on the dumps again who shows up and
manages to get his ask back on track
well no one other than his big bro of
course Toto out of all of his teaches
like namami Gojo choso even I guess at
some points and Toto here I find it
funny how yui always progresses to an
even higher degree in some aspects with
Toto by his side Toto's just talk no juu
incarnate right now also while I'm off
on this tangent check out some of the
like new merch I've been making recently
I'm trying to make it more anime based
instead of just like the Tex stuff I had
beforehand and include things from a
variety of different series that I've
covered in the past so if you have any
moments that you'd like to see on the
shirt from a bunch of series that I've
covered let me know down below and I'll
see what I can cook up anyway back with
the fire mjo shape shifts his fingers
into a Long double-edged Blade and tries
to stab Yuji with it countering Yuji
parries the hand and grabs the spike by
catching it between his fingers throwing
a fat Kick towards mjo from behind Yuji
attempts to throw the curse into his
partner mjo attempts to counter by
transforming his free arm into a spiked
Vine and lashing it at Toto the grade
one sorcerer though claps to switch his
position with a curse and lands behind
Yuji avoiding the attack doing the same
weird thing as just like before Mido
swaps his body's polarity to avoid
taking a possible hit from behind he
then quickly enlarges both of his arms
and uses his forearms to block Toto and
Yuji from capitalizing on the situation
taking a moment to think to himself M
recognizes that Toto was at full health
and doubts One Touch from Idol
Transfiguration would be enough to kill
him when it comes to yui though he
believes that that the student is
nearing his end at only around 10% left
himself after all of the attacks he's
taken thinks he's probably at around 40%
surprisingly M admits that even though
nobara is a nobody she managed to leave
her mark on the fight with the damage he
done on him sucking his hands back to
his original size Nito knows that he
first needs to deal with a switching he
transforms his left arm into a fin-like
slicing weapon to fend off Toto and
tosses a transfig human out of his right
hand at huji Toto immediately switches
his place with the transfig human to get
behind the curse taking mjo completely
off guard who actually slices his own
ability in half looking like a stunned
mullet now mjo was unaware Toto was even
able to switch places with a non-l
subject and is impressed with how he
picked up on his transfigured humans
energy before he even released it
feeling himself now Toto believes that
his friendship with Yuji can't last if
he remains stagnant even now meito this
this dirty r of a cur Spirit can use
black flash he pers if it's him that's
being left behind now asking himself if
he's going to allow his brother to feel
alone once more AOE Toto transcends who
he once was to step up unleashing his
first ever use of a black flash again
and just like before with Yuji the blow
is powerful enough that it shatters
mjo's blocking arm and sends him sliding
back across the station although unlike
yui this has no effect on mjo's Soul due
to him not possessing that ability sadly
how
now that all three of these individuals
have released their black flashes the
cursed Spirit recognizes that all three
Fighters are reaching 120% of their
maximum potential randomly something
starts swelling up inside of mjo's mouth
instantly after the curse vomits
numerous small transfigured humans into
his hand and crushes them all together
in his palms to activate Soul
multiplicity with no warning the jacked
up mjo immediately unleashes body repel
creating several giant monstrous mouth
to attack the two stun Sorcerers the
technique is so demonstrably strong that
it easily breaks the ceiling of the
subway spewing itself into the streets
of shabuya above ground being like the
brute genius he is Toto recognizes that
mahito is countering boogy Wy at this
moment by attacking from every single
Direction at top the mass of
transfigured humans NATO screams out to
Yuji that this is it it's their last
chance to curse each other mad cuz this
freak somehow forgot about him Toto
claps placing mjo right next to him
uncon for his own safety at this point
cuz he wants to prove a point he
straight up tackles the curse to the
floor allowing a piss Yuji to follow up
and kick a man while he's down unnerved
mjo quickly detaches his own head before
Yuji could kick it off mjo's detached
body spawns its own freaking bug likee
head while simultaneously spinning its
blade arms rapidly nearly cut into two
Sorcerers while Toto jumps above one
blade arm Yuji Ducks below the other
giving mjo's detached head time to form
its own separate body slamming a few
Souls together mjo activates Soul
multiplicity a technique in which all of
the souls with weak rejection come
together to form one body known as the
polymorphic soul I this in my opinion is
that why this battle is so freaking to
here mjo's JoJo stance there behind his
stand ass looking soul isomer but more
or less what I'm trying to say about
this is this dude's constent ability to
evolve over time is actually crazy every
day he must have just been tankering
away in the silver system with his
ability trying to craft the most devious
and soul violating weapons he could
figure out he is an utter demon and like
how he taunts Yuji is just phenomenal
and I I love the relationship this is
just the Pinnacle of it right here
anyway anyway flashing back to the heat
of the battle Toto claps repeatedly and
continues to switch positions between
the five fighters on the platform he
believes that M's original dismembered
body contains 80% of his power while the
head possesses 20 the plan is for Yuji
to finish off the detached head while
Toto takes care of the transfigured
human which he guesses is probably like
around a grade two or three fre curse
however Toto grossly underestimates the
polymorphic Soul icy most power and is
caught off guard by a powerful back
first reeling from a hit so hard it had
to have been Yuki or his dad hitting him
Toto can do nothing as the polymorphic
salt ismore follows up with a r hook
that se the grade one sorcerer crashing
through the side of a nearby building
continuing the uncontrollable path Toto
falls out the other side of the building
stunned from the impact the polymorphic
Soul iyore jumps above the injured
Sorcerer And attempts to crush him on
the way down luckily Toto lands on his
feet and is able to avoid the follow-up
kick from his opponents picking up a
piece of flying Rubble in the process
Toto imbus it with cursed energy before
tossing it at the soul icur instantly
Toto switches with the rock to get right
behind his opponent and delivers a
powerful right Hawk that literally turns
the polymorphic Soul iyore into a
freaking pancake to totto surprise the
transfigured human only took one hit
because the psi's explosive power comes
from expanding so many weak Souls at
once standing there Toto figures out how
the transfig human attack Specialists
work just as two more arrive to confront
him feeling free from Toto's
interference for a bit mahito piles only
the pressure against Yugi slamming his
hands down he activates body repel
creating long ill likee transfigured
head with spikes along the side to
attack Yuji gets between each of the
attacks in order to find an opening to
drop kick mahito the curse counters by
grabbing yui's leg and throwing him into
the ground below the impact breaks the
ground apart and sends yui's body along
the Street back to the area of sakon's
Destruction while Yuji is reing from the
pain of the hit M moves in to capitalize
on the situation however the curse is
disappointed to find out that Toto has
suddenly rejoined yuji's side standing
there big Pro Toto taunt meito for
really trying to avoid a two-on-one
fight as in his eyes this is a freaking
beating blowing away with like how not
even two polymorphic Soul iyov were
enough to St Toto he knows that Landing
a hit on him will be difficult and using
the domain expansion with Yuji around
will invoke zuna's rage at this current
Point meito can't configure his barrier
to exclude specific people so there is
only one thing he can resort to on a
whim he decides to employ a technique he
saw a specific demon used earlier on in
shabuya the special grade decides that
it's all or nothing and activates his
domain expansion the self- embodiment of
perfection for z.2 seconds instantly
Toto responds by cing a simple domain
that he learned from Yuki even faster
though and unconcerned for himself in
this Yuji boosts forward towards mjo in
an attempt to exercise him before he
could activate Idol Transfiguration
sadly for the two brothers though the
fastest was mjo who had already awakened
through black flash usually when cast in
a domain a sorcerer first needs to
realize in anate domain then activate
the instant effect of a curse technique
inside of that domain thanks to his
Awakening due to black flash though
meito was able to pull off this
unrealistically F fast combination all
of a sudden mahito enters sakuna inate
domain and tells him to shut up and
watch as yui will be dead before they
can even switch places back in Shibuya
mito's self- embodiment of perfection
disappears just as quickly as it was
cast looking down Toto watches as
suddenly his left arm transfigures
concerning Yuji who stops dead in his
tracks running up Meo punches Yuji from
behind and knocks him to the ground
thinking on the spot Toto quickly acts
and sers his own hand using curse energy
however this leaves totally defenseless
against mjo's next attack unable to
activate Idol Transfiguration so soon
after cas's domain though mego instead
opts for a physical attack and lands a
devastating Direct Hit to Toto's guts
with black flash the power obtained in
mjo's Black flashh sends Toto shooting
back across the destroyed area of
shabuya despite suffering a direct hit
Toto somehow survives and is able to
land back on his feeds Blown Away with
how in the world he survived Mido
notices that the s concentrated all of
his cursed energy to the area of the
impact in order to minimize the damage
ignoring the minor setback mjo's cursed
technique returns and he repairs to in
Toto with his next use of idol
Transfiguration Toto's necklace which
was slightly cut back when he cut his
hand off before suddenly Falls and cl is
open revealing a picture of yui along
with the idol that Toto loves in that
moment a catches mjo's eye and distracts
him for just a second this gives Toto
just enough time to clap using mjo own
damn hands in order to activate Boogie
WGY one more time having slapped that
hand Toto switches places with Yuji who
somehow knew what was about to happen
and is already in the middle of swinging
a devastating right hook watching the
fist approaching M realizes his
predicament far too late before he is
struck directly in the face by yuji's
black flash nearby Toto lays on the
ground looking at his hand grateful that
it's only slightly burned from touching
meito Beck in the the battle and
extremely thankful for all of the help
so far in this fight Yuji looks back
towards his big bro and silently thanks
him but now he's going to take it from
here heavily injured now Meo activates
Soul multiplicity and creates another
polymorphic soul isomer to hold off Yuji
the Sorcerer And the transfigured human
trade pares and punches in quick
succession while mahito hangs back
trying to regain some breath Meo admits
that getting hit with black flash at
this stage of the fight is bad and
commends Toto for being a pain in the
ass until the very end the special grade
quickly disregards this because he
believes he's found the truest essence
of his soul after unleashing black flash
for a second time in front of him Yuji
quickly uses a spinning C to defeat the
polymorphic Soul icy Mo before turning
his attention back to mjo looking at the
patchy curse he notices mjo changing his
shape along with a massive burst of
curse energy being emitted by the
process activating Idol Transfiguration
once more the Cur Spirit sheds its human
like a parent and evolves into its final
form the instant Spirit body of
distorted killing feeling reborn Meo
asks Yuji to celebrate the occasion by
wishing him a happy birthday standing
there Yi can feel that this
Transfiguration is unlike any other and
wonders what improvements it brings to
his opponents happy with himself Meo
explains that because he's learned black
flash he finally understands his true
unbridled Soul screwing up his face in
disgust Yuji jokes that he didn't take
mjo as one for a journey of
self-discovery jokingly agreeing with
him the curse also believes that he's
just getting started and only once he's
killed Yuji can he truly feel born a new
using the improved strength granted by
inant Spirit body of distorted killing
meito whips his hand and creates a giant
shock W to try and take the sorcerer out
yuji's reflexes are fast enough for him
to roll under the whip like a pinage and
dive straight into a head Ki Meo who
like bro what are those glasses he's
wearing now what is that head what what
even is it on his head it's it's like a
crown I do like the look of it but he's
he's probably got like tough level
auditory spec and he somehow avoids the
head kick while at the same time
wrapping the tendrils around yuji's foot
before you know instantaneously after
retracting the tendrils wounding the
student's foot in the process the cursed
P follows up by whipping his tail at the
sorcerer but somehow Yuji manages to
block the strike with his KN getting in
close to each other now Mido throws a
lift hook still Yuji parries the attack
and delivers a Swift hit to the body
while mjo's hand is deflected making
things even more difficult for our boy
though it turns out that mjo's transform
state provides skin so tough it even
surpasses Cho's heart and blood and
nullifies yuji's attack with one arm
blocked Mido uses his free arm to attack
with the tendril blades on the back of
his elbow this slash cuts open the side
of yuji's blocking arm and allows mjo to
capitalize while his adversary is on the
back foot darting in Meo follows up with
a flurry of Rapid blows each with an
increasing speed and ferocity Yuji is
like initially able to deflect
everything proving just how naturally
gifted the dude is but he soon finds
that his counterattacks aren't reaching
mjo at all this show of strength forces
the sorcerer to recognize that mjo has
evolved into a completely different
being than before his transformation
breaking through the faltering guard M
grabs yui's face and slams him into the
street destroying the ground from the
impact and collapsing them back into the
train tunnels of shabuya the falling
Rubble then smashes the piping causing
the crater to slowly begin filling with
water standing in a pool of water Yuji
knows that the only way he can achieve
Victory Is by Landing a black flash no
more specifically he needs to lay him
out with a black flash imbued with his
maximum cursed energy remembering the
time he was told that there isn't a
single sorcerer who can use it at well
yui slightly loses his footing due to
the general exhaustion and the ground
beneath his feet giving way due to the
water Meo attempts to take advantage of
yui's small laps by rushing in however
the Cur Spirit immediately stops the
tendrils on the back of his elbow
partially disintegrate and the patch
face goon even begins coughing up blood
cracking up at how tired he's become
meito knows that getting hit by black
flash so soon after activating domain
expansion seriously injured him Yuji on
the other hand bangs on his leg in order
to wake it back up and regains his
balance amused with their final standoff
mjo states that both of them still have
plenty left in the tank kicking the
fight back off mahito makes the first
move creating a giant Splash in the
water from his incredibly fast movements
Yi immediately clenches his fist and his
palm and channels all of his cursed
energy into it bursting through the
water M attempts to attack Yuji from
behind but our boy Ducks under the
strike in time before easily powering
the curses follow-up strike facing each
other and with nowhere to run now Yugi
and mojito prepar to let loose with
their own powered up strikes so inside
of Jiu-Jitsu Kaizen not a single
sorcerer as we know has been to use
black flash at well in this moment of
battle though Yuji has performed so well
with it that he fools you making you
think that that's exactly what he's
doing m is fully aware that that yuu
will try and end the fight using black
flash he knows that going in recklessly
will end in his demise and so in
preparation has set in motion a
countermeasure in the midst of their
exchange of punches Meo partially
deactivates the instant Spirit body of
distorted killing to the left side of
his body catching guji surprise he plans
on transfiguring his body to avoid the
attack while also reinforcing the
deactivated area with cursed energy with
Yugi's curse energy completely focused
in his fists M believes his neck is wide
open and that's how he'll end it here as
suspected Yuji lands a fat hit on the
deactivated area of mjo's body believe
in he one now mjo swings forth at yuji's
neck with his elbow however in that
moment a sudden second impact completely
throws off the trajectory of mjo slash
dumbfounding the silly curse so you see
back in the past dant fist was born out
of yuji's bad habits and over time he
corrected them losing the technique in
the process but earlier on in shabuya
and ever since his fight with choso yui
has been able to control Divergent first
and has used it to disrupt mjo's plans
having ducked underneath mjo's previous
attack Yuji prepares his own while mjo
nervously tries to slash back with his
elbow suddenly a familiar voice tells
the curs spirit to listen closely as
there is no way he doesn't know this
fact already looking like he himself
hthy Toto stands above the crater still
determined to help his best friend he
tells the cursed spirit that an arm is
merely a decoration and while swinging
his limbs together one last time states
that the act of Applause is the
acclamation of the Soul itself due to
Toto's Charisma and the threat of buggy
wagy activating just before H
immediately Ely turns around to
anticipate the switching places he
slashes behind him but hits nothing but
ear completely fooled by the utter
Genius of a big brother looking down
with a smile Toto apologizes for lying
and claims that his boogy Wy curse
technique has already died set up with a
clean shot from his bro Yuji lands a
devastating direct maximum cursed energy
black flash hir to the cursor's rib cage
seeing him shooting off smashing into
the top part of the crater before
finally stopping back above ground
stumbling around like a complete buffoon
now and back inside of his normal form
Madeo attempts to vomit up more transfig
humans trying to fight back but he's
completely run out strolling up to the
curse Yuki admits that mahito was right
after all he's him he wanted to reject
majito and convince himself that the
curse was wrong but that doesn't matter
now he's going to murk his ass anyway
even if he comes back as another curse
he'll kill him change your name face or
form he'll sto will be there to kill him
no longer needs to find some form of
meaning or reasoning from exercising
curses maybe 100 years or so later after
his own death the meaning of those
actions might become apparents and the
grand scheme of things he's probably
nothing more than a cog but that no
longer matters to him for as long as he
lives this this is his role seeing
yuji's determination to fulfill his role
as a Jutsu sorcerer made fleas terrify
for the approaching Doom like a wolf
running down a here in the snow Yi looks
down upon his prey and stalks him with
an intent not his scen suddenly an even
greater wolf arrives when krpi yaku
appears before meito asking if he'd like
to be saved so that there brings us to
the very end of like Yuji and Toto
versus meso here obviously you know Yuji
doesn't exactly yet to close out that
kill which is is kind of sad in my
opinion it would have been nice for him
to close it out but it is kind of
against his character he's the the whole
Batman of the Jen Universe and
everything so I didn't expect him to you
know go ahead and actually close it out
at one point I really did though towards
the end of the fight where he fully
turned on mjo and was like I know what I
am now I'm a cog I'm about to dig your
grave and put you in it man so come here
it was it was by far the best fight
throughout shabuya I know it's probably
not the most destructive out of all of
the fights throughout shabuya but in my
opinion it's definitely the best just
for like the story that happens for like
how m character and everything Yuji he
finally gets to progress we get past
meso and everything who's you know like
the initial main villain and we move on
to you know more of King jaku and find
out a little bit more about him and this
whole calling game and the setup for all
of that it's a it's a brilliant way to
set up that part of the story and I
really really liked it obviously I'd
love to know all of your thoughts down
in the comment section below so make
sure you guys do all leave them down
there if you are new arounder then make
sure you do subscribe to keep up to date
with a bunch of similar content just
like this but for a whole bunch of other
anime series and of course make sure to
leave a like as well if you have enjoyed
the video as it really helps out with
pushing my content to a bunch of new
amazing people either way it's been your
professional degenerate deolo and I will
see you all in a BS bye